voilà ouais
bonjour j'ai une commande de six pizza
pour le bureau 4
note encore fait le con avec le
téléphone sharif
bonjour
vous avez des pizzas non non
oui
une piste normal avec fromage
d'accord combien de temps 10 minutes
d'accord je porte de saint-cloud aux
trois obus merci
c'est vrai qu'on aime pépin c'est moi
voilà
vous commandez les pizzas ailleurs est
vraiment j'ai ici les costauds comme
maintenant pourquoi je sais pas on fait
restaurants ont fait brasserie on n'a
pas besoin des produits des offres ouais
mais vous n'avez pas de pizza j'ai
demandé il a indiqué ne pas pouvoir vous
avez donc serial
ya pas de terrasse seria et
c'est pour ça que j'ai commandé la garde
et c'est tout le monde fait ça on fait
quoi on vous prête de chaises découvert
de l'unpi quand vous avez plus qu encore
mais vous fait votre pizza va sur le
devant en face c'est normal en fait mais
là j'ai pris une entrée chez vous avez
une entrée vite vous un cap et la sortie
des douches ont mené ce coup dur avant
l'effondrement
non non ça se voit un jour vous vous les
voyez à côté on se livre à un côté pu
manger là ça va pas vraiment ont des
gens pour des imbéciles et vous n'avez
pas de pizza vous suivez depuis sa jambe
en étudiant prenez pas
pourquoi mais son ami ron non vous
n'êtes pas idiots et
ah
non ça c'est à moi c'est moi vous partir
avec tout ça la 1e manche et les fans
voilà
alors maintenant on y arrive on m'avait
tout seul au monde et les folles dans la
perte ça on produira pas du tout robben
très bon non vous n'êtes pas très
serviable lorraine en valeur auprès non
non non allez-y vous avez une petite
serviette
c'est au bon accueil chez vous non ouais
avait vu ça ouais maintien merci dégage
voilà tu dégages ouais je connais vous
dégagez faire plus et
voilà c'est bien gentil voilà qu'est ce
qu'on fait bah je dis au revoir 1 on
s'embrasse non non pas du tout
moussaoui
[Musique]